welcome back to las vegas now the more
medication you're on the harder it is to
keep
up or take things properly so southwest
medical is back to share some advice on
taking medication
the way you're supposed to take a look
so we're talking medical adherence what
does that mean
well surgeon general c everett coop once
said drugs don't work in patients who
don't take them
we call this medication adherence which
means taking your medications the way
you're supposed to
the full benefits of medications are
often not realized because people
don't take their medications as
prescribed and why is it important for
people to be open and direct
in talking with their health care
professionals about the medications and
supplements
they're actually taking using
prescription drugs over-the-counter
medications
and vitamins or supplements at the same
times can cause your prescriptions to be
ineffective or dangerous sometimes
for example antibiotics or
anti-inflammatories such as ibuprofen or
aspirin can cause serious bleeding when
used with blood
thinners using some pain medications
with alcohol or certain other drugs like
xanax or valium
increases the risk of overdose or death
doctor what are some of the reasons why
people do not take their medication the
right way
there may be many reasons that people
don't take their medications
as prescribed some people may not be
convinced the medication is working for
them
some people are concerned or fearful of
side effects or having difficulties
taking their medications
especially when they have to self-inject
or
use an inhaler some people cost is a
factor
and sometimes people just forget
and what ways can your provider help
with this
well healthcare is a team effort so it's
important to talk to your
doctor and pharmacist and share your
concerns with them
and more importantly ask questions
it's good to keep an updated list of
your medications
and take it with you to each of your
doctor's appointments
and let's talk about more benefits for
the medication checkup
medication checkup is pretty easy but it
can have big benefits it can help you to
find
possibly dangerous combinations you may
be taking
identify improper dosages or mistakes
you may be making
you may also ask about side effects the
correct time and sequence to take each
of your medications and supplements
and what drugs could be taken with or
without food
this review of your medications can also
help simplify your daily regimen by
identifying medications
you may not need to take anymore or by
recommending an extended day supply
which means you can get a 90
or 100 day supply of medication
depending on your insurance
each time when you fill them you will
have a refill of your medication
less frequently and what are some of the
options that southwest medical patients
have
compost medical we have an electronic
medical record that you can access
online or
with a telephone app by accessing your
medical record
you can have a review of your records as
well as prescription renewals
as well as a daily list of your current
medications
southwest medical patients can also
access a tab called
e-visits where they can email their
physician
and ask questions about medications or
other health-related concerns
southwest medical has locations across
southern nevada for more information
call that number on your screen or just
visit
smalv.com we'll be